[Music]
my family
means everything to me and i am
fiercely loyal to them i'm family first
job second i put my colleagues here
who i believe are the best in the
business in a bad spot
i never intended for that i would never
intend for that
and i am sorry well an insincere apology
from cnn's chris cuomo after he admitted
to advising
his governor brother on me too
allegations what is this
his fourth ethics violation
at cnn for the coverage of his brother
and zero repercussions
canceled culture just can't catch the
cuomos and to be clear
cancel culture is still alive and well
just today an ap
reporter was fired for pro-palestinian
tweets she posted when she was in
college
last week an apple employee was fired
for something he wrote
over five years before he was hired for
his first day of employment
at apple the list goes on and on these
people didn't lose their jobs because of
merit or the market that's not what
canceled culture is cancelled culture
is cowering in fear it's bending to the
will of a small
radical minority and in the end maybe
that's why the cuomo seemed to get a
free pass
immunity if you will from cancel culture
because
forget what they say no matter how many
things they do wrong
andrew cuomo being caught up in both a
nursing home cover-up and
a sexual assault sexual harassment
scandal
chris cuomo becoming an ethical and
journalistic
nightmare none of it seems to matter
they can't be canceled they're
covered listen to the members of the
view just today
chris cuomo is my friend he is my
colleague and i love the guy
and so it's difficult to speak about
people you know and you love
on tv to be unvarnished and objective
about it i actually don't think um
that he should be punished he's been
very transparent and let's face it there
are so many people in the media
that are hired because of their access
you know
it's not difficult to tell the truth
it's not difficult
when the repercussions are larger than
one person and that's what we're looking
at
when it comes to both cuomo brothers the
repercussions spill over
far and wide joining me now to react is
new york gubernatorial candidate
andrew giuliani john giuliani andrew's
so good too you know i shouldn't i
shouldn't fumble your last name because
that's key here andrew
i wonder now listen i i mean it i i
wonder andrew
why is it the cuomo brothers are getting
away with this and i think the answer is
the last name
it is elitism and look to be fair you
have a last name
that is very well known you have a last
name that is going to serve you
throughout your life so you can speak
uniquely to this andrew
do you think they are getting special
privileges based upon
just that name well i think they are but
i think
the further point of this is this is a
great microcosm
of the connection between cnn and
leftists in the media
and the democratic party i mean look
project veritas just a few weeks ago
exposed
cnn as self-admitted propagandists so i
think this is even
much larger than just the cuomo name
right there and it's okay you fumble the
name will i've seen it spelt wrong
on campaign ads before so it's giuliani
g-i-u-l-i-a-i don't worry about it
well i've said it more than once in my
life so i don't know why i would mess up
the first time i say it
in connection to you um you know you
know this is
the point of this is not to attack any
one individual it truly is not
but i think what these brothers
essentially now represent is that there
are classes of people
in this society that can be i guess in
this case canceled or treated in a
certain way
and classes of other people in this
society who get special exceptions who
get special privileges
who simply can be protected who it
doesn't even matter we're not even
talking about what they say as i said
andrew
what about everything they've done yeah
well what i would say is i think this is
really just journalistic malpractice
by chris cuomo i mean the truth is look
i'm glad he apologized
but really what i'm waiting for is the
apology from andrew cuomo
how about the 15 000 nursing home desk
that's what i want
i want that apology for the for all the
new yorkers that had to suffer
through his policies that are going down
to florida right now
it's unacceptable so i'm waiting for
that apology and i got to tell you will
look for any new yorker that does want
to change for any american
that wants a change and knows the
importance of it please come and support
us because
i really think we have a great chance to
go and turn around new york
right now and i got to tell you one
thing cnn certainly wouldn't treat me
like that
that's for sure that is i think that is
for sure they would not treat you like
that you bring up an interesting point
you're not just here as a commentator
on whether or not chris cuomo has
violated journalistic ethics which he
clearly has you're not just here as a
commentator on andrew cuomo scandals
you're running against andrew cuomo at
some point you're wanting to be the next
governor of new york and i want to do i
do want to ask you this andrew people
people in their criticism of you the
main thing they point to is a lack of
experience what do you say to those who
question your experience
well what i would say is over the last
four years i've been working in
president trump's administration
specifically in the last year and a half
i ended up working
on the paycheck protection program to
make sure that
all of the american businesses all the
american jobs that were shutting down
what should have been temporarily
shutting down
in 2020 that all of those workers got
their paycheck right there
i ended up working on the cares act
making sure that the mta
got their first two tranches of funding
i ended up working on the 911 health
victims fund to make sure that 3.9
million dollars
got reimbursed which was fault of the
new york state department of finance so
what i would say is
while i would become the youngest
governor surpassing only teddy roosevelt
by a few months
i think i have a lot more experience
than most 35 year olds and i got to tell
you
for any new yorker any american who
feels that way go to ny for giuliani.com
and please support us we can use all the
help we can get we can use all the help
we can get
all right i do think this city this
state is ready for a change
andrew giuliani best of luck in making
the case that you are the man for that
change in new york thanks for being with
us tonight
will thanks for having me have a great
weekend you bet unfortunately
my weekend doesn't start till midweek
next week but i appreciate that hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else